todo
[Música]
hola hoy en science click la gravedad
según einstein en el siglo 17 newton
descubre la gravedad universal gracias a
ella consiguió predecir el movimiento de
una manzana al caer de un árbol o la
órbita de la luna alrededor de la tierra
sin embargo newton no llega a explicar
por qué existe la gravedad ni cómo actúa
es necesario esperar a principios del
siglo 20 con la teoría de la relatividad
general de albert eisntein para
responder a estas preguntas primero que
todo para ainstein las tres dimensiones
del espacio y el tiempo en el que nos
desarrollamos son sólo dos caras de una
misma moneda el espacio-tiempo en el
espacio-tiempo los objetos existen en un
lugar dado en un momento dado
ahora intentemos imaginar el espacio
tiempo como una cuadrícula en la que
podemos ubicar un objeto y cuando se
encuentra en la cuadrícula la
distorsiona según su masa
cuanto más masivos sea el objeto más
distorsión hará el espacio-tiempo a la
inversa cuanto menos masivo menos sé
perturbará el espacio-tiempo
ahora imaginemos que ponemos un segundo
objeto ve en esta cuadrícula ve también
distorsiona el espacio-tiempo ya que
posee una masa pero menos que a ya que
la suya no es tan elevado
veamos ahora qué ocurre si lanzamos una
canica en un tazón debido a la geometría
curva del tazón la canica se deslizará
por el interior hasta que se detenga en
el centro del mismo modo cuando pensamos
en el espacio-tiempo a crea una suerte
de tazón cuando distorsiona la
cuadrícula así al igual que una canica
ve se deslizará a lo largo de este tazón
acercándose poco a poco
si observamos esta escena desde arriba
vemos que ve es atraído por a al igual
que en el modelo de gravedad de newton
ahora bien si soltáramos ave en este
tazón con cierta velocidad este le daría
vueltas mientras se acercaba
finalmente si pudiéramos soltar ave con
una velocidad suficientemente grande me
empezaría a dar vueltas alrededor de a
si nunca a acercársele es así como los
planetas orbitan alrededor del sol
al igual que newton la teoría de
einstein predice el movimiento de los
planetas alrededor del sol sin embargo
hacer más completa esta teoría también
ha permitido descubrir muchas otras
primicias científicas como el hecho de
que una densidad muy importante puede
dar origen a la aparición de lo que
llamamos un agujero negro
[Música]